[Music]
everybody can be part of her team coke
I'm outside a market or dressing room
its pre-show they're doing rehearsal
right now I'm gonna go in talk to Martin
and see what a second to be all about
let's go on in excuse me mr. short
didn't mean to get you in the middle of
hi how are you know is that something
you do before patty hi I'm Jimmy Jimmy I
work on the program yeah oh my god in
heaven
Wow that's that's that's not fresh bread
oh is that true I just took the mint no
yeah you know what the secret is with
you Jimmy what's not take to next time
here's the thing Martin what talk to you
about escape that's good as tight as we
can we got a one shot here we're on TBS
so a lot of the guests come in they they
phone this thing in they they got you
don't have to show up on reality make
the commitment but they don't give a
hundred percent yeah listen you always
do a terrific job whatever you're on the
problem thanks is it what you need okay
Jimmy Jimmy
yes let's go this way I'm really here to
promote my appearance on Letterman
okay well it's knit on the seam so hot
that you would come on this program it
is it appears on another program it very
much does it very well you're gonna get
the suit pressed just for this show if I
made I saw some clips on YouTube I
wouldn't touch my arm as much as you
want to you were the one who said let's
get close yeah it's a it's like America
America can invade a country mhm but
that country can't invade America like
that that's right I can do that that's
right I can do that right and you can't
go any closer yes no you gotta keep it
here what am i coming like this no no
take it back clothes dress yeah Saturday
night did you do that you want to hear
me do it yeah it's Saturday night love
well you see Don can't you know do the
show forever he's already 140 you think
I think they want someone with the
medication all balance and stuff now see
but I think you could certainly
recommend someone that they might then
take off that list because they would
have a long list initially and they'd
want to weed it down so you think they
would
me too just to make that list shorter
who are your thoughts and I go I think
you should good I'll throw out a
different I'm Neil Patrick Harris not
gonna hire your instinct is the kind
that when you hear it you listen to it
and you're reverse all right listen I
want you to go out there thank you let's
do this thing
it's your day Conan O'Brien Conan
O'Brien Conan Conan Conan what did you
think you were george is Howie Mandel
still do talk
[Music]